tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel
triomphe de margaret thatcher première
femme à la tête d'un gouvernement
européen
le tiercé les hausses essence 11
centimes fuel 5 centimes électricité cet
ennemi pour cent après les malades et
gorgés de l'hôpital de maison blanche
le problème des urgences psychiatriques
poser une nouvelle fois un procédé
révolutionnaire pour l'opération de la
cataracte le cristallin artificiel
les explications de pierre bergé bonsoir
eh bien oui c'est un grand moment pour
les femmes c'est ce qu'a dit margaret
thatcher elle-même après la victoire de
son parti le parti conservateur aux
élections
c'est en tout cas un grand événement en
grande bretagne la dame de fer a montré
aujourd'hui sont plus large sourire
après 20 ans de carrière politique
cette maman de jumeaux de 25 ans un fils
et une fille qui a pu dire que le plus
beau métier du monde c'était de rester à
la maison pour s'occuper de ses enfants
est bien là devenu premier ministre de
grande bretagne
les choses vont d'ailleurs très vite
dans la tradition britannique certes dès
ce matin on savait que le parti
conservateur avec gagner mais c'est
seulement dans l'après-midi qu'on a su
officiellement que la majorité absolue
de 318 siège avait été atteinte par le
parti conservateur par le parti de
madame thatcher
pourtant et ceci peut nous étonner en
france la passation des pouvoirs étaient
déjà pratiquement faite avant la
proclamation des résultats définitifs
madame le premier ministre après la
démission de james callaghan est allé
s'installer au 10 downing street la
résidence des chefs de gouvernement ceci
après avoir vu la reine évidemment andré
salariés nous fait revivre cette journée
à londres
mindshare a franchi cet après-midi les
grid buckingham palace à bord de la
voiture officielle de l'opposition
l'opposition de sa majesté selon la
vieille formule qui fait sourire les
anglais elle a gagné à trois heures de
l'après midi elle a dépassé la barre des
3 118 sièges la majorité absolue dans
cette chambre des communes qui compte
635 débuté cette nuit elle accueilli
avec joie mais avec prudence les
messages annonçant son succès ce soir
épuisé est heureuse elle a dit aux
journalistes je vais travailler demain
je vous en dirai plus sur la formation
de mon gouvernement et mon programme
james callahan a perdu mais il est beau
joueur il quitte le devant de la scène
politique avec beaucoup de panache nous
sommes fiers at il dit que la
grande-bretagne soit le premier pays
occidental à avoir une femme comme
premier ministre c'est un grand moment
dans la progression des femmes vers
l'égalité avec les hommes
les britanniques ont vécu dans la fièvre
cette nuit et cette journée historique
la télévision bbc et télévisions
indépendantes ont été mis pratiquement
toute la nuit et toute la journée les
anglais s'étaient souvent groupé pour
suivre et commenter le résultat la
presse avec son énorme tirage populaire
la presse favorable dans sa majorité aux
conservateurs a clamé sa victoire il y à
un autre perdant aujourd'hui
jeremy flores ancien leader des libéraux
accusé d'avoir tenté de faire assassiner
un homme qui le faisait chanter dit rémi
top député du nord des bonnes depuis 20
ans s'il avait été élu il se serait
présenté la tête haute devant ses juges
fort de l'appui de ses électeurs mais
ils n'ont abandonné mardi prochain il
passera en cours d'assises avec ses
quatre co inculpés les libéraux n'ont
pas réussi dans ce scrutin à se poser en
arbitre les écossais ont montré que
l'indépendance ne laissa signe pas les
nationales france n'est pas parvenue à
faire prendre au sérieux ses positions
extrémistes de droite la nouvelle
chambre des communes entrera en séance
au début de la semaine prochaine
la lenteur du dépouillement fait que
nous n'avons pas encore les résultats
complets des élections nous les aurons
seulement les auront seulement que
demain matin
ce que l'on sait c'est que les
conservateurs ont obtenu un peu plus de
44 % des voix et les travaillistes un
peu plus de 38% inde et fut un des plus
faibles résultats pour eux pour les
travaillistes depuis 35 ans d'ailleurs
ce que ce que je peux vous dire aussi
c'est qu'un anglais a gagné chez les
bookmakers
chez un bookmaker 387 mille francs 43
mille livres pour avoir parié que les
conservateurs auraient la majorité
absolue il est vrai qu'il avait misé
très gros cela dit une fois la surprise
passée car c'en est une tout de même
cette victoire des conservateurs
on pensait que les sondages s'était
trompé une fois de plus et il faut leur
rendre cette justice ce n'est pas le cas
alors donc une fois la surprise passée
madame thatcher se mettant au travail il
faut déjà envisager ce qui risque de
changer en grande bretagne et pour nous
aussi
gérard saint paul toutes proportions
gardées les britanniques viennent de
connaître et de déclencher un phénomène
électorale de type suédois en renvoyant
dans l'opposition la social démocratie
souvenez vous ce que l'on avait appelé
la vague verte en suède lors des
précédentes consultations dans ce pays
avait balayé le pouvoir social démocrate
d'olof palme comparaison limite il y a
un peu de cela
en effet madame thatcher a axé toute sa
campagne électorale contre la trop
grande sollicitude de james caan à
l'égard de tout le secteur assisté en
grande bretagne pour une réduction du
gaspillage pour une diminution de
certaines dépenses sociales trop
importante pour un abaissement des
impôts directs en augmentant les
contributions indirectes
bref libéralisation à tout prix pour
redonner vie et souffle à l'économie
britannique
quelle sera la réponse des syndicats qui
sont très pragmatiques ici sans doute
dans un premier temps des grèves très
sérieuse dans le secteur public pour les
12 mois à venir
toutes ces pesanteurs sociales avec
lesquels la madame thatcher va devoir
compter limiteront sa marge de manoeuvre
sur le plan européen les conservateurs
ne remettent pas l'europe en cause
ils ont les mêmes soucis très
britannique réduire les dépenses de
londres payer le moins possible
réviser la politique agricole sur le
plan mondial après les déclarations
fracassantes de maggie thatcher à
l'égard de l'urss
le foreign office new look à l'épreuve
des réalités diplomatique devra mettre
de l'eau dans son thé mais les
britanniques exigeront une détente plus
sourcilleuses à l'égard de moscou
ils ne seront pas toujours à 100%
d'accord non plus avec les états unis
car ils redoutent les flottements de
jimmy carter et sur le plan bilatéral
vis-à-vis de la france bien les
conservateurs sont dans les meilleures
dispositions d'esprit pour le prochain
conseil européen
exit james callaghan et voici une femme
à la tête d'un pays européen
sa victoire marque aussi autre chose sur
le plan international c'est un peu le
recul de la mouvance je ne dis pas du
bloc social démocrate de l' influence de
la social démocratie au nord de l'europe
madame thatcher prendra des initiatives
elle essaiera de relancer l'image de la
grande-bretagne sur le plan mondial
mais est-ce que l'intendance suivra
baptise prestia nous ici londres terre
si madame thatcher est la première femme
européenne à devenir premier ministre il
faut se souvenir qu'avant elle d'autres
femmes exercer le pouvoir dans les mêmes
fonctions
madame indira gandhi en inde madame
baranek au sri-lanka l'ancien ceylan et
madame golda mère aujourd'hui décédée en
israël elles ont gardé le pouvoir
respectivement 11 ans 12 ans et 5 ans
madame simone veil s'est déjà réjouit de
l'avènement de blâme satcher monsieur
giscard d'estaing aussi et cela au cours
de l'émission forum de radio monte carlo
qui sera diffusée demain mais dont voici
déjà un extrait sec tard elle que nous
sommes six essais de ne pas intervenir
de ne pas porter de jugement dans les
affaires intérieures de nos partenaires
c'est d'ailleurs une règle dont nous
souhaitons qu'ils s'inspirent également
nous avons été conduits à le rappeler à
certains d'entre eux lors de nos
élections de mars 1978
je m'en tiendrai à cette règle et j'irai
seulement que la france respecte le
choix des électeurs britanniques pour ce
qui est de du premier ministre gd
conduit à dire depuis quatre ans combien
je souhaitais que se développe le rôle
des femmes dans la vie politique et dans
l'exercice des diverses responsabilités
c'est pourquoi je serais heureux de
travailler avec le nouveau premier
ministre britannique d'une part dans le
cadre de nos relations régulières
bilatérales et d'autre part dans le
cadre de notre
vos communautés oui c'est à villeneuve
sur lot qui a été enregistrée ce forum
de radio monte carlo 18 journalistes de
grands quotidiens régionaux ont
interrogé monsieur giscard d'estaing sur
beaucoup de questions politiques vous en
saurez davantage de main sur le contenu
de cette émission
le voyage du président à villeneuve sur
lot a été rapide après l'enregistrement
il a déjeuné en privé chez jean françois
poncet le ministre des affaires
étrangères qui est aussi président du
conseil général du lot-et-garonne qui
réside à lusignan ensuite le président a
regagné paris
ici un sondage de popularité celui qui
publie chaque mois le figaro magazine un
sondage sofres 56% des français font
tout à fait ou plutôt confiance au
président de la république qui gagne
deux points dans ce sondage raymond
barre gagne également deux points mais à
seulement 39 % de réponses positives
madame simone veil reste en tête avec 58
% 1 point de plus dans l'opposition
michel rocard est à 47 % françois
mitterrand gagne quatre points c'est la
remontée la plus spectaculaire à 44%
dans ce sondage
on vous avait prévenu qu'une nouvelle
hausse de l'essence avaient intervenir
au mois de mai eh bien avec quelques
jours d'avancé c'est décidé c'est pour
ce soir 0-1 le super l'essence super va
passer de 275 à deux francs 86 et
l'ordinaire de 254 à 265 ça fait dans
les deux cas 11 centimes d'augmentation
le gazole augmente de 6 centimes il
passe à 1 franc 85 et le fioul
domestique pour le chauffage augmente de
5 centimes il coûtera désormais un franc
0 3 et comme le prix de l'électricité va
augmenter lui aussi deux sets et demi
pour cent dans les prochains jours
la france qui grelotte encore au mois de
mai va regarder avec anxiété ses
factures de chauffage
comparons avec un avait l'air qu est ce
qui coûte le plus cher le gaz le fioul
ou l'électricité
depuis le début de la crise du pétrole à
l'automne 1973 tous les types de
chauffage ont augmenté bien sûr mais
dans des proportions très variables
le prix du fioul x 3 2 36 centimes le
litre en octobre 1973 à 1 franc 0,3 à
partir de demain
l'électricité + 50 % seulement le
kilowattheure en basse tension
valait en moyenne 20 centimes cette en
1973 il en vaudra 32,8 avec la nouvelle
augmentation de 7 et demi pour cent qui
interviendra vraisemblablement lundi le
gaz enfin de 5 centimes 60 le
kilowattheure en 1973 son prix est passé
à 10 centimes 30
un peu moins du double au moment où
éclatait la crise du pétrole le mode de
chauffage le plus économique et de loin
était le fuel puis venait le gaz est
enfin d'électricité or depuis 1973
on voit que c'est le fuel qui a le plus
augmenté puis vient le gaz bien que
cette fois ils échappent à la hausse et
enfin l'électricité qui a subi la hausse
la moins forte
est on parvenu à un rééquilibrage à
titre purement indicatif on peut estimer
aujourd'hui pour une même maison de 100
mètres carrés que le budget énergie sera
de 4400 franc avec le tout électrique de
2009 s'en prend avec le chauffage au gaz
de 2700 avec le chauffage au fioul
ce n'est pas encore le nivellement mais
presque pour le gaz et le fioul
le tout électrique restant la solution
la plus chère il est vrai que
l'électricité est encore fabriquée à 60%
à base de pétrole
les pouvoirs publics ne tiennent pas
favoriser son développement tant que le
nucléaire n'aura pas pris la relève
voilà la solution économique ce serait
peut-être de se chauffer au bois
je ne plaisante pas ça existe aussi pour
le chauffage central world ya aussi le
soleil mais comme il est très rare
social d'abord l'annoncé d'une grève
nationale dans la fonction publique
elle est prévue le jeudi 17 mai par la
cgt la cfdt et la fen pour appuyer les
négociations en suspens dans la fonction
publique notamment sur les salaires
force ouvrière et les autres syndicats
n'appellent pas à la grève
d'autre part on va reparler de la durée
du temps de travail à côté de la
revendication quasiment européenne pour
parvenir à réduire la durée du travail
hebdomadaire de 30 à 35 heures ce qui ne
sait ce qui n'est pas pour tout de suite
il y aura à la fin du mois le 30 mai la
reprise d'une grande négociation sur la
durée annuelle du travail entre le cnpf
et les centrales syndicales
cette négociation avait été interrompu
en novembre dernier le thème est vaste
complexe
il s'agit de définir une durée annuelle
du travail que les salariés et les
entreprises
reese répartiraient à leur gré
respectifs tout au long de l'année
en somme il s'agit d'instituer des
horaires variables non plus au mois mai
à l'année dans le cadre de cette
négociation
et ça c'est plus concret le patronat va
faire une proposition précise l'octroi
de jours supplémentaires de congés qui
d'une certaine façon et sans que le mot
soit prononcée pourrait représenter
jusqu'à une cinquième semaine de congés
payés selon quel système et à quelles
conditions
françois gaulle explique et bien ces
jours de congés supplémentaires seraient
accordées aux salariés ayant effectué
dans l'année un certain nombre de jours
de travail
le système serait dégressif
regardez-bien 232 jours de travail par
an donnerait droit tu as un jour de
repos supplémentaire soit une semaine en
plus 231 chevaux de travail à quatre
jours de repos supplémentaires 230 jours
à trois jours
229 jours à deux jours enfin 228 jours
donnerait droit à une journée de repos
supplémentaire
certains jours seraient par ailleurs
assimiler un travail effectif
les jours de congés pour formation
permanente par exemple ou bien les
heures de délégation pour les délégués
du personnel
les membres du comité d'entreprise ou
les délégués syndicaux et cette liste
n'est pas limitative
le projet du cnpf bien sûr est séduisant
toutefois les syndicats estimeront sans
doute que la barre des 2 132 jours est
fixé très haut en 1978 par exemple en
tenant compte des week-ends des jours
fériés les quatre semaines de congés
payés
les salariés français ont travaillé 232
jours en 1979
ils auront travaillé 233 jours mais
attention tout cela sans tenir compte
des ponts des maladies ou des événements
familiaux
toutes choses qui font partie de la vie
quotidienne cela étant cette proposition
représente une base de discussion entre
le cnpf et les syndicats la formule sera
négocié dans le détail
rendez-vous le 30 mai
je ne suis pas le seul à me demander
comment on a pu laisser se produire le
terrible drame de l'hôpital
psychiatrique de maison blanche à
neuilly sur marne dans la seine saint
denis
comment un malade mental a pu être
laissé en possession d'un couteau avec
lequel il a tué cinq malades de son
dortoir et on a blessé trois autres dans
une crise de démence
le couteau était plutôt du genre canif
c'est vrai une lame de 7 cm pourtant il
a tué cinq fois avant que le meurtrier
ait pu être maîtrisé il était 5h30 du
matin c'était cette nuit l'homme un
algérien de 37 ans avait été admis une
heure et demie plus tôt il s'était
d'abord présenté de lui-même accompagné
d'un ami parce qu'il ne se sentait pas
bien à l'hôpital claude bernard où il
avait déjà été soigné pour alcoolisme
mois d'avril là on jugea que son et a
demandé un examen psychiatrique au
centre psychiatrique d'orientation de
l'hôpital sainte anne à paris on le
dirigeait sur neuilly sur marne
à son arrivée il ne présentait aucun
signe d'agitation
rien ne laissait prévoir sa crise il a
donc été admis en service libre et placé
dans un dortoir de 10 personnes une
heure et demie plus tard c'était le
drame cinq victimes plusieurs accidents
moins graves mais de même nature se sont
déjà produits dans cet hôpital de maison
blanche d'où le communiqué des syndicats
dénonçant le manque de personnel et
faisant remarquer que deux infirmières
seulement étaient de garde la nuit
dernière dans ce pavillon qui abritait
38 malade en tout alors ici il faut
répéter la question comment ce drame
at-il pu arriver alain rodier oui
comment une admission banal ici à
l'hôpital de maison blanche cette nuit
at elle pu déboucher sur un massacre
c'est en effet la question que chacun se
pose
il faut savoir que lorsque la fsa oui
arrive cette nuit à maison blanche
il est en placement libre c'est à dire
qu'il est venue tout simplement pour
consultation sur avis médical bien sûr
mais de son plein gré il est libre de
ses mouvements il n'a pas d'antécédents
psychiatriques
il ne présente aucun signe apparent
d'agressivité c'est la raison pour
laquelle il n'est probablement pas
fouiller des mesures beaucoup plus
contraignantes sont prises lorsqu'il
s'agit de placement d'office sur arrêté
préfectoral ou de placement volonté
m à la demande d'un proche c'est-à-dire
dans ces deux derniers cas lorsque le
malade présente un danger évident pour
la société dans ce cas le régime
d'internement est beaucoup plus sévère
mais revenons aux faits dans le dortoir
où l'on installe la fsa oui il y a deux
femmes deux infirmières qui surveille 38
malade c'est la norme administratif
seulement on ne sait rien de la fsa oui
et lorsqu'il se déchaîne les deux femmes
sont impuissantes
c'est là le problème la maison blanche
comme dans les autres centres on manque
d'hommes on manque de bras musclés le
syndicat national des psychiatres
déplore cet état de fait
estime que l'évolution actuelle est
cependant originale et intéressante de
l'hospitalisation psychiatrique implique
tout de même une augmentation du
personnel soignant
devant cet état de fait faut-il
considérer alors chaque malade comme
dangereux faut-il fouiller tout le monde
à l'entrée y compris ceux qui sont en
placement libre
les spécialistes bien sûr disent non la
psychiatrie a évolué on regarde le
malade
autrement les infirmiers eux-mêmes
subissent une formation de 33 mois
bref l'hôpital ce n'est plus la zil
carcéral le monde à part que l'on
connaissait encore il ya 20 ans alors
direz vous il y aura d'autres l'afssa
oui dans ce domaine certes le risque est
permanent et le personnel soignant ne le
cache pas reste tout de même une
solution reconsidérer la notion
d'urgence en psychiatrie c'est à dire ne
plus amenés en pleine nuit au milieu
d'autres malades en traitement des
sujets qui n'ont pas subi un examen
approfondi nos yeux vieillissent nos
yeux se fatiguent
c'est normal pour beaucoup d'entre nous
cela s'arrange avec des lunettes
mais pour d'autres pour 50 à 60 mille
personnes par an tout de même cela se
traduit par l'opération de la cataracte
et bien sûr ensuite par le port de
grosses lunettes
or dans ce domaine ya du nouveau le
congrès de l'association française des
implants oculaires qui se tient
actuellement à cannes et auquel
participent plusieurs centaines de
spécialistes à étudier les avantages et
les indications d'une opération
particulière de la cataracte au cours de
laquelle un véritable cristallin
artificiel est mise en place à la place
du christ à la normale reportages et
enquêtes pire des anesthésies générales
un malade va subir l'opération de la
cataracte pourquoi son cristallin petite
lentille ronde transparent qui est une
partie du système optique de l'oeil
s'est pacifié
le sujet est alors menacé de ne plus
voir l'opération a pour but d'enlever le
cristallin devenu incapable d'assurer sa
fonction après incision de la cornée le
cristallin que voici est retirée de
l'oeil
on distingue nettement qu'il est devenu
complètement opaque
il va alors être remplacés par ceux
cristallin artificiel en plastique dur
qui est glissé à l'emplacement naturel
du cristallin malades rendu libre par le
geste opératoire précédent aux français
d'intervention représente un avantage
physiologiques importants pour la vision
du malade mais nous n'entrerons pas dans
des détails scientifiques je crois que
ce qui est important c'est le confort
visuel des malades lorsqu'ils sont
opérés en effet de manière classique
lorsque l'on fait une cataracte
il faut corriger la vision par le port
de lunettes
quelquefois une paire de lunettes
souvent de paire de lunettes quoi qu'il
en soit ces lunettes ne permettent une
vision centrale et une mauvaise vision
périphérique
alors avec l'implantation d'un christ à
l'artificiel
nous arrivons à obtenir qu'une vision
centrale et périphéries bol est la
meilleure donc considérablement le
confort du mal et je crois que c'est une
intervention qui n'est peut-être pas
possible de réaliser dans tous les plats
de cataracte
mais en l'améliorant l'augmentera les
possibilités et les invitations s'est
opéré de la cataracte porte un
cristallin artificiel
nous allons faire un test simple qui
permettra d'apprécier si l'une d'entre
elles a récupéré une certaine vision
latérale alors nous commençons fixe et
moi bien vous me regardez jeu
demander à ce monsieur d'entrer dans la
salle et vous dirai quand la sphère
seulement vous dire et je le vois
regardez moi bien voulez vous rentrez
monsieur regardez moi bien madame diois
voulez-vous me dire que là où si vous
apercevez l'acrobate deux motionnaires
venelles satin regardez moi je le vois
pressée il ya du jeune il ya du bleu et
un peu de rouge
ainsi dans certains cas très précis mais
pendant tous le chirurgien entraîné à
cette technique peut proposer un
cristallin artificiel
les autres nouvelles de ce journal avec
vous jean claude narcy d'abord la
réunion à paris des membres de la liste
udf aux élections européennes en
présence de simone veil et de jean
lecanuet qui a déclaré à cette occasion
que la liste livre aurait le bon combat
pour le bon choix
le mouvement des jeunes radicaux a
décidé de constituer une liste euros
jeunes justement le 10 juin prochain
ouverte à tous les jeunes partisans
d'une europe fédérale et social georges
marchais écrit dans le monde aujourd'hui
le 23ème congrès du parti communiste
sera le congrès de l'ouverture ce sera
un congrès ouvert sur la vie sur les
préoccupations réelles des françaises et
des français
chez nous n'ont cours ni les batailles
procédurières ni les tournois de ténor
ni la course aux places
ainsi dans la à la seule maire de fos
sur mer après le vote de la grève des
accidents donc se sont produits en début
d'après midi à l'entrée de l'usiné
sidérurgique entre les cadres et les
ouvriers deux personnes ont été blessées
dans des bayards air france envisage
d'utiliser deux concorde supplémentaire
c'est ce qu'a déclaré aujourd'hui agence
france presse le président de la
compagnie aérienne monsieur giraudet en
italie les brigades rouges ont encore
frappé des coups de feu ont été tirés
devant le domicile du secrétariat
général de la démocratie chrétienne
annappes et à turin plusieurs incendies
criminels ont été allumés l'attentât
d'hier contre le siège romain démocratie
chrétienne était sans aucun doute le
signal de départ d'opérations
terroristes
à l'occasion de la campagne électorale
italienne en iran plusieurs attentats ce
matin des inconnus à moto ont mitraillé
le siège des comités khomeiny en plein
centre de téhéran
quelques heures plus tard des rafale de
pistolet mitrailleur ont été tirés sur
la place du parlement
au liban trois militaires néerlandais de
la finul ont été capturés par les
milices chrétiennes et puis quatre
blessés dont un grièvement à tours ce
matin à la suite de l'explosion d'une
bouteille de gaz dans un immeuble de 18
étages
la violence de la déflagration était
telle que tous les derniers étages a été
détruit et la toiture souffre les dégâts
sont donc importants mais les habitants
des étages inférieurs n'ont pas été
obligés de d'évacuer leurs appartements
92 mille candidats vont passer demain
les épreuves du permis de chasser et les
questions posées porteront sur la
réglementation de la chasse bien sûr
mais aussi la sécurité et l'emploi des
armes à feu ainsi que sur la
connaissance des espèces animales
décidément les centrales nucléaires
américaines connaissent bien des
déboires cette fois ci il s'agit de la
centrale de eastern creek dans le new
jersey qui est victime d'un arrêt
automatique et ne sera pas remise en
service sans une autorisation préalable
de la commission fédérale dont les
inspecteurs se sont aperçus que cet
arrêt était le résultat d'une série de
mauvais son fonctionnement qui aurait pu
conduire un accident du même type que
celui de la centrale de three mile
island il y encore des pionniers dans le
domaine de l'aviation cette petite
trapanelle comme disent les aviateurs
est en fait le premier avion alimenté
par énergie solaire regardez bien nous
sommes à morgane ville en californie et
voici l'appareil des piles solaires sur
les supérieurs des accus pour alimenter
un moteur électrique et larry moreau le
constructeur et pilote réussit le
décollage vous l'avez vu évidemment nous
n'en sommes pas encore au gros porteur à
énergie solaire et attention surtout au
jour depuis
oui et puis alors ce petit avion bon bah
c'était seulement un essai
j'espère qu'il va perfectionner son
appareil le sport et la politique
vous avez entendu hier soir dans ce
journal le ministre de la jeunesse et
des sports jean-pierre soisson dire
qu'il y aurait une réunion de trois
ministères pour étudier les modalités
qui permettront d'empêcher la tournée en
france de l'équipe de rugby d'afrique du
sud
d'autre part vous savez que les
responsables sportifs et olympique
français avaient maintenu leur
invitation pour les springbocks des
joueurs de rugby d'afrique du sud à
l'automne prochain et le gouvernement a
tranché pour ne pas apporter une caution
au régime sud africain et à sa son
régime de ségrégation raciale
le mouvement contre le racisme et pour
l'amitié entre les peuples félicite le
gouvernement de sa décision
il n'en va pas du tout de même pour le
président de la fédération française de
rugby monsieur ferrasse vous allez
l'entendre pour lui décidément on ne
devrait pas mélanger sport et politique
ou alors écoutez bien non ça me fait mal
ça fait beaucoup de peine pas seulement
pour moi bien sûr mais pour tous une
tour nos amis quoi tout le rugby tous
les sportifs ce désaveu public infligé
au comité national français et à la
fédération prennent au lycée d'une très
mauvaise chose parce qu'à ce moment-là a
l'impression est ma certitude que c'est
la politique qui prend le pas sur le
sport alors il ne reste plus maintenant
qu'à monsieur collard de faire une liste
pour se présenter avec un mouvement
sportif aux prochaines élections
européenne et à ce moment là on comptera
les vrais sportifs et on comptera ce qui
fonde le problème de la politique pour
leur ment comme nous sommes des gens
d'ici mais pour le moment rien de fait
et nous le resterons avec le comité rue
peel français d'ailleurs sur nos
positions
c'est à dire que vous attendez de
confirmation écrit exactement
voilà c'était un reportage de fr3
toulouse
le temps est bien tout arrive à part
quelques baisses sur le de température
sur la normandie sur la plus grande
partie de la france est impératif et
demain c'est sûr
le temps va continuer à s'améliorer sur
la plupart des régions avec cependant
des nuages assez abondants près de la
manche et de la mer du nord et des
pluies ou des averses peu fréquente sur
les autres régions le temps sera
ensoleillé
après la dispute la dissipation de
quelques brouillards matinaux quelques
passages nuageux donneront toutefois
quelques averses aussi sur la moitié
nord les températures maximales matinale
pardon seront encore basses avec des
gelées dans l'intérieur
mais les températures maximales c'est à
dire en cours de journée elles seront en
hausse
-dimanche l'amélioration devrait se
développer avec encore de rares averses
du nord aux vosges et aux alpes voilà ce
journal est terminé dernier journal
jacques le noir vers 23h40
merci de l'avoir écoutée au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité